[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur tv 78 nouvelle
édition en ce 2 juin du 7-8 politique et
dans un peu plus de deux semaines
maintenant nous nous rendront aux urnes
pour désigner nos conseillers régionaux
et puis nos conseillers départementaux
nous irons d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
dans les cantons de rambouillet de
mantes la jolie en intendance et de
l'élection régionale en ile de france
dont il est question avec babette de
rozières qui est en ligne avec nos bons
jours babette de rozières présente sur
la liste de valérie pécresse dans les
yvelines vous êtes en cinquième position
sur la mandature qui s'achève vous étiez
déjà élu vous étiez a chargé notamment
de la cité de la gastronomie
et puis je rappelle que vous êtes chef
de cuisine notamment un bol avec la case
de babette qu'on aperçoit justement
derrière vous alors vous qui est déjà
bien occupé professionnellement
justement pourquoi ce nouvel engagement
pour une nouvelle mandature avec valérie
pécresse
vous savez à 6 ans je me suis engagé
auprès de valérie pécresse
et si je continue chose et puis pendant
six ans on apprend à connaître vraiment
qui est la présidente de vision et je
peux vous assurer c'est une femme
bâtisseuse et c'est ça qui est forte
elle est libre elle sait ce qu'elle dit
c'est pas quelqu'un qui a la langue de
bois et c'est pour ça que compte tenu de
son énergie du travail de la fonderie
pendant six ans la risée de france a
décidé de suivre combat avec les
capitaines et quand j'ai quitté pas de
capitaine même si un jour on me le
demande sur le quitterai jamais parce
que c'est une femme qui a le sens du
devoir qui a aussi la reconnaissance et
qui bossent énormément c'est une femme
pâtissier vraiment et c'est sûr que nous
avons les mêmes valeurs
vous êtes restauratrice aussi on l'a dit
pendant cette crise de sanitaires la
région est venu en aide un auprès des
restaurateurs des entreprises si on
parle justement du programme pour vous
sur la prochaine mandature ces aides cet
accompagnement envers les restaurateurs
même si la situation on l'espère va
continuer à s'améliorer doit se
poursuivre il va falloir maintenir ces
aides
absolument non seulement un métier
s'exerce avec la vision avait accordé
les prêts les diggers des libéraux dont
le président savait déjà ça on va
abandonner justement cette partie là
pour les commerçants voulaient se
dresser et en plus on va toujours être à
leurs côtés parce que vous savez la
période de pandémie a été est
mon compliqué où les restaurateurs nous
avons mis en place pas mal de paramètres
de ted pour leur permettre de sortir de
cette crise on était aux côtés du
gouvernement
il y en a peut-être même terre plus que
le gouvernement puisque non seulement
pendant la période du 1er confinement à
leur a permis de travailler sur les
terrasses gratuite en ile-de-france que
avec les maires bien sûr ensuite la
chine à celle du pesto faut leur permet
justement de commencer à travailler avec
des aides ce qu'on appuie des accords
avec des partenaires alors à 2500 euros
un chèque numérique donc pouvoir se
mettre aux critiques en colère on leur a
donné 1000 euros selon loyer pour leur
permettre d'alléger un peu le plaidoyer
et là encore on va leur donner de la
moitié 1000 euros pour leur permettre
d'installer encore des terrasses
gratuite sous le domaine public dans en
ile de france
on est vraiment au côté les
restaurateurs et puis à paco les
restaurateurs il a aussi il ya aussi des
intermittents du spectacle de la
restauration
ce sont des gens qui sont parents
engagés qui n'ont pas de contrat et qui
travaille néanmoins toute l'année avec
des restaurateurs
on les avait complètement oublié et là
encore par eddy a fait tout son possible
pour les aider
90e les restaurateurs sont bien soignés
avec nous mais n'ont pas à se plaindre
que nous avons renforcé les formations
aux métiers de bouche parce que vous
savez avec cette pandémie
il ya beaucoup d'employés de
restauration qui ont changé qui ont
changé d'orientation et donc nous en
forme au livre on forme des jeunes aux
métiers de bouche pour permettre
justement ça faut qu'il y ait ce métier
là et nous savons qu'il ya aussi le parc
où la somme est répartie et je veux
pourquoi que le premier site du parc ou
ouvre le 10 juin
là c'est l'hôtel de la marine place de
la concorde c'est un bijou et il ya
vraiment tout ce qui se voit tout ce qui
se mange
vous allez être épatés par cet endroit
qui normalement n'était pas vouée à la
casse vraiment sur la situation des
restaurateurs je profite de vous avoir
avec lui avec nous pour cette émission
vous avez évoqué cette situation aussi
quelquefois de reconversion qui s'est
opéré pendant la période de pandémie
est ce que les restaurateurs vont
pouvoir reprendre une activité est ce
que beaucoup de vos confrères vos
concerts on
d'ores et déjà jeté l'épongé est là il y
en a beaucoup et fait savoir qu'il ya
3500 hôtels et restaurants qui ont fermé
quand cet été les pauses 2000 à paris et
on prévoit entre 30 et 40 pouces encore
dans les mois à venir
mais vous savez ceux qui sont ouverts la
maintenant ils ont repris confiance
parce qu'on avait besoin de cette
bouffée d'oxygène parce que la
restauration city music hall ont choisi
quand on est chef de cuisine c'est une
passion donc être privé de cette passion
l'a évidemment y en a plein qui ont
déprimé mais maintenant je vois
l'engouement ils ont réouvert comme
immeuble aux terrasses eh bien ils sont
fin prêts pour réattaquer est renouvelée
justement ce métier est fermé mais ce
n'était pas des jeunes parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de jeunes qui au vu de faire ce
métier et on a beaucoup qui était déjà
des métiers qui sont partis et la
maintenance des décorateurs en confiance
et puis évidemment ils peuvent s'appuyer
sur des êtres de valérie pécresse et ça
leur permet d'avoir un peu plus de
sérénité pour pouvoir commencer à
travailler
alors qu'ils tournent un peu peut-être
les fourneaux parlons d autres priorités
pour vous sur la prochaine mandature
quelle sera la priorité des priorités
c'est toujours occupé des métiers de
bouche et de la notation en général
parce que vous savez j'ai été élu dans
la première mandature m'occuper de la
cité-etat gastronomie et je veux
pourquoi que maintenant elle arrive à un
point où on va acheter le terrain pour
fabriquer et construire la cité de la
gastronomie à paris xixe mais à côté ça
je ne sais pas rester à ne rien faire
y accueillir un parcours avec six sites
emblématiques en ile de france
donc vous voyez j'ai entendu plein sous
la plante et puis tout ce qui a trait à
la gastronomie vous savez c'est
tellement basse et puis ça rapproche
d'astronomie ça on n'est pas fâché du
tout d'une belle à zéro dans notre
culture d'abord comment de cette nacelle
j'ai une dernière question vous vous
revendiquez comme une femme de droite
mais une femme néanmoins libres vous
n'êtes pas apparentés un parti politique
aujourd'hui les discussions qui portent
autour du rapprochement des républicains
avec le rassemblement national
comment vous le percevez est ce que est
ce que vous ça vous affecte et vous
aimeriez aussi une clarification des
positions à droite moi c'est vrai
j'aimerais une qualification parce que
moi même je suis l air et moi ça me fait
beaucoup de peine de voir eux
la droite un petit peu partagé moi je
suis pour le rassemblement et j'ai
confiance dans la droite pour se
rassembler pour que tous les élèves sera
sans moi le front national je ne sais
pas ce que ces gens parlent de passer
par an 6 et mais seulement suggèrent ses
dettes
lr foncière mahler est à côté d'eux mais
donne mes collègues pour leur permettre
de rassembler au maximum parce qu'on ne
peut gagner que si on y rassembler merci
babette de rozières candidate donc sur
la liste de valérie pécresse dans les
yvelines pour ces régionales en île de
france
merci à vous nous poursuivons cette
émission avec la campagne des
départementales dans les yvelines à
présent et direction donc rambouillet
pour débuter cette page départementale
dans ce canton quatre binômes se
présente celui du rassemblement national
celui d'europe écologie les verts
un binôme sans étiquette également et
puis à celui de la majorité sortante et
c'est le président du département lui
aussi en campagne qui est venu rendre
visite donc aux tic et clarisse
demongeot from the cutting pour sa
majorité
reportage michael et lui droit pierre
bédier en déplacement dans le canton de
rambouillet le président sortant du
département des yvelines est venu
rencontrer le duo clarisse de mon
geoffroy backs de keating candidats au
départemental
ils se sont retrouvés au vaccinodromes
de rambouillet salle patenôtre seront
des voix également permis de constater
le déploiement du dispositif et yes plus
sur le site
cinq jeunes sont concernés sur le centre
de vaccination ce dispositif a prospéré
nous l'avons réactiver et intensifiées à
l'occasion de la pandémie dont mise à
disposition de jeunes en recherche
d'emploi ou de jeunes étudiants
mise à disposition des collectivités
pour qu'ils participent à l'origine
c'était vaincre la solitude des
personnes âgées en période estivale
et là c'est l'accompagnement de toutes
les personnes dans ce procès juste de
vaccination dans la matinée pierre
bédier également campagne pour sa
réélection et le binôme clarisse de
montréjeau prend bex de keating se sont
rendus dans les locaux de la gendarmerie
de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines un site
rénové à hauteur de 225 mille euros par
le département les gendarmes ne sont pas
sous notre responsabilité
mais les bâtiments de la gendarmerie le
sont donc je venais vérifier là
effectivement que les travaux qui
avaient été programmées convenait
répondait bien aux attentes de ces
gendarmes c'est le cas et j'en suis ravi
parce que si on veut avoir une sécurité
marche au service de nos concitoyens
encore faut-il que ceux qui assurent
cette sécurité pour nos concitoyens
puissent le faire dans des conditions de
travail convenable le déplacement de
pierre bédier s'est terminée par la
visite de la ferme dort son lit une
exploitation spécialisée dans la pomme
de terre qui fournit les cantines des
collèges du département
sur le canton de mantes la jolie à
présent où se présente justement pierre
bédier pas moins de sept binômes en lice
à la gauche est divisée ainsi le
communiste marc jamais elle n'a pas
souhaité faire alliance avec europe
écologie ou encore la france insoumise
il nous explique son projet avec sa
colistière interview menée par eléonore
sinoquet
[Musique]
s'il continue cas et moi je suis
conseillère municipale de clermont que
le colis sied vraiment rien strictement
rien à la politique
il ya beaucoup de choses qui me
scandalise et donc c'était une
obligation pour moi de m'engager pour
faire changer les choses à mon goût pour
les huit candidats de la république le
lot on est tous différents avec des des
parcours des parcours différents mais on
est tous des élus et des candidats laïcs
ça ça nous semblait que nous semble
important on est les seuls par exemple
avoir faire un programme de 12 pages on
réclame notamment le gong rené fonds
publics
nous ne sommes pas comprendre d'accorder
des fonds publics et des entreprises
pour leur permettre d'évoluer mais nous
réclamons le contrôle des fonds publics
il faut qu'elles nous disent qu'elles en
font et il faut qu'on comprenne
échangiez grèce si on envoie en bois de
proximité
même sous la pluie ont fait campagne
on est deux bases on a toujours été dans
la terreur le sera toujours
vous avez faire campagne c'est pas à se
montrer partout comme corps beaucoup ont
fait campagne en étant nous mêmes
voilà et particularités évinoise pour
ces départementale une ville est
partagée en deux cantons c'est celle de
versailles une ville de canton et au
total une dizaine de binômes candidats
versailles sera coupée en deux cantons
pendant ces élections départementales le
canton de versailles 1 ne comprend
qu'une partie de la cité royale et
représente 65 mille habitants le canton
de versailles 2 regroupe quant à lui une
petite partie de versailles notamment
satory quatre autres villes
environnantes
ce redécoupage a été pensé en 2014 et
s'explique par la forte démographie de
la ville avec ses 85 mille habitants
quinze mille de plus que la moyenne d'un
canton au total dix binômes sont
candidats sur ces deux cantons d'en
verser à on retrouve cinq binômes
philippe holtz terrienne jacquemin du
rassemblement national
une liste divers avec marc de fouquières
et anne-marie ropert les écologistes
stéphanie bella et françois wauquiez une
liste et les oem est menée par laurent
de bastard et en france si mon objectif
c'est de poursuivre
de notre projet progressiste aversa il
représentait notre électorat est fou
c'est nos idées il est important c'est
dans l'adn dedans marchande avoir de
renouveler un petit peu le visage des
politiques renouveler un peu seul
personnel dans l'adn dans marche d'une
façon il faut il faut je pense qu aider
des gens d'univers différents d'horizons
différents de sensibilités différentes
et qu'on puisse avancer
de cette façon il y à aussi nice tech
les candidats sortants claire chaigne
aux forains et olivier de la faire ce
serait de continuer à accompagner les
collèges de versailles bien entendu
puisque c'est notre canton et aussi
poursuivre le soutien au bloc communal à
la commune de versailles puisque ça fait
partie des axes principaux de la
politique départementale que ce soutien
aux communes et aux intercommunalités
continuer notre action c'est aussi
pérenniser tout l'action qu'on a pu
mener depuis six ans sur le territoire
auprès dé versailles et auprès des
yvelinois parce que c'est un enjeu
important aujourd'hui le département
pour soutenir toute l'action sociale du
territoire mais aussi l'attractivité de
notre territoire et également soutenir
le bloc communal comme qu'hervé viens de
le dire dans le canton de versailles
dont on retrouve également cinq binômes
la liste écologiste avec maïté caribe
douaniers hugo hors sol un
le rassemblement national et joël alain
et philippe prouver une liste divers
centres avec tony antonio c'est karine
laurentin marie hélène aubert et olivier
lebrun des candidats divers droite et
enfin une liste divers gauche avec
jean-albert guillet c'est sophie paris
pour se mettre aussi réaliser des
projets qui prennent en compte les le
climat donc des réalisations qui qu'ils
soient écologiques et enfin dernier
point c'est bien faire participer les
yvelinois aux décisions du département à
travers des référendums ou à travers des
dés
budget participatif on trouve que pour
le moment les yvelinois sont trop couper
des décisions prises par le département
et on voudrait davantage les inclure le
premier tour des élections
départementales est programmée le
dimanche 20 juin
et si ce découpage des cantons est
toujours obscures pour vous nous allons
vous expliquer pourquoi certaines villes
sont regroupés ensemble dans un
découpage donc parfois très complexes
mélanie poquet fait le tour des 21
cantons des yvelines 21 cantons c'est le
découpage électoral dans les yvelines
pour les élections départementales pensé
lors du redécoupage dès 2014 le nombre
de cantons dans un département comptant
plus de 500000 habitants ne peut être
inférieure à 17 avec près d'un million
cinq cent mille habitants
les yvelines sont donc passés de 39 à 21
cantons dès le scrutin de 2015
un peu d'histoire les limites des
cantons ont été tracées en 1801 le
redécoupage de 2014 c'est le fruit d'une
volonté gouvernementale de tenir compte
des évolutions démographiques et les
nouvelles délimitations s'appuie sur les
chiffres de l'insee de 2013 alors
comment sont répartis les commune
yvelinoise chaque canton doit désormais
regroupé le même nombre d'habitants avec
une marge de plus ou moins 20 %
explications un million cinq cent mille
habitants / 21 cantons cela nous donne
une moyenne de 71 mille habitants + 20 %
nous amène à 85 mille habitants
c'est le cas de sartrouville le canton
le plus peuplé des yvelines avec 83
mille habitants -20% cette fois ça nous
donne 56 1800 habitants dans les
yvelines c'est le cas du canton de
limoux qui est composé de 57 mille
habitants alors pour respecter cette
répartition la composition des cantons
peut sembler un peu disparate par
exemple comptons de bonnières-sur-seine
regroupe soixante neuf communes maurepas
elle quitte son canton composé de
coignières elancourt et la verrière la
commune saint-quentinoise rejoint le
canton alors appelé de chevreuse avec 14
autres communes maurepas et temps là la
plus grande ville le canton de chevreuse
prend le nom de maurepas il y à aussi
celui de montigny le bretonneux qui est
composé de
de communes monts tinée et guyancourt et
le cas le plus particulier c'est celui
de la ville de versailles puisqu'elle
est coupée en deux le canton versailles
ne regroupe qu'une partie de la cité
royale et représente 65 mille habitants
celui de versailles 2 et l'addition de
cinq villes bucs jouy en josas les loges
en josas viroflay et vélizy villacoublay
et bien sûr la deuxième partie de
versailles le 7-8 politique revient
mercredi prochain cette émission est
disponible en replay sur notre site
internet et sur notre application mobile
à noter aussi que la semaine prochaine
patrice carmouze recevra dans
l'entretien politique cyril notre ancien
maire de mantes la ville candidat pour
le rassemblement national sur le canton
a demandé la jolie à bientôt
[Musique]